hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to powerwash simulator
this one isn't going to be nearly as
long as the others because we have
arrived at the last thing
that is available
in powerwash simulator
the recreational vehicle
i've done
every level in every way possible
this is one of the new ones that they
added and yes they're working on new
levels
but i thought it was fitting that i
didn't just leave this be
and i actually finish it
and i'll take my time with it i honestly
will because
oh look at this bad boy i also saw that
on twitter the developers behind this
game are looking at or asking people
what do you think the lore is of this
game and i know that there is a dark
secret lurking in this town somewhere
like it's too pristine
wait can you
i was about safe i could just walk down
the street that would have been very
creepy there's probably like a secret
path in one of these levels that no
one's ever seen before and
you know no one's ever paid attention to
and it's all been gone whatever anyway
i'm gonna take my time with this one i'm
gonna really get it in detail let me
think actually how i want to attack this
because it's a big van it's got some
pretty crusty sand in there graffiti
rust all the good stuff can i climb oh
come on developers this game is
literally unplayable you have a ladder
in the back of this and i can't climb
the ladder in the back of the rv to get
to the top i have to use my ladder for
some reason literally i have to place
the ladder next to the ladder that is
already on here
literally unplayable did you even bother
to try to test this because it's clear
that you did not anyway what i'm gonna
do is i'm just gonna go through and i'm
gonna i'm gonna clean as i see fit
and i'm going to do with my trusty
let's go green to start with i want to
see what kind of stuff this can get
just wanted to see how grateful jenny
and i are for everything you've done for
us it's really helped us get on get on
our feet
oh
well that's very nice you're welcome
i can't remember who you are but i'm
glad that i could help it sounds silly
but washing the house when no one else
would made such a difference and as for
the car
oh that's so nice
no why would you be so nice
i don't know i'm getting sad when i
complete these things
oh
diner cleaned already
that's the good stuff
it's probably like some kind of a zen
challenge you could do for yourself by
just like washing everything with either
the
the zero degree nozzle the red one or
just with the uh the spinning thing oh
this isn't even a separate item it's
it's all part of the same body
[Music]
i don't know why but i feel like washing
all the little details first
and then getting the larger ones
that feels right
and i get to use this thing and do that
zen thing that i was talking about
probably some on the top or like the
inner side here
there we go
the last thing
the last washable
i'm sad now
i'm sad
this game has changed my life forever
i'm not sure if i'm joking about that
i'm really not sure because i look at
things differently like i was vacuuming
the other day and i looked at it like
okay i gotta i can't just rush through
this i gotta complete each section
because the vacuum was just this tiny
handheld vacuum and i'm like okay let's
see
if i really wanna get into the
nitty-gritty of this then you know
i gotta i gotta be slow and methodical
about it i was like oh no
oh no
powerwall simulator is teaching me a
life lesson oh no so i can't exactly
tell if i'm joking as far as um
you
know it's changed my life or not but man
is this game good
god damn good game i can't believe it's
taking this long for someone to realize
the potential of this because i know
that people have known that that power
washing is just such a satisfying
adventure
and uh to have it in game form done well
too you know i want to see i want to see
some other power washing games you know
let's see if get some competition see
who can make the best power washing game
they got a head start here though gonna
be hard to beat
is that rust
is that some rust on this hatch hmm
this is definitely the slower approach
but you know there's really like this
van is going to be done before i know it
i'm just going to be like oh crap
i guess i maybe shouldn't have rushed it
oh who drew flowers on this that's
lovely
very nice
it also teaches me not to be so tense
because i have a habit of like really
tensing up when i'm like ooh fine motor
control but honestly like actually
relaxing is a much better strategy to
dealing with um fine situations just
slow down a bit and take your time and
wouldn't you know it it gets done all
the same okay that's most of the details
on this side i think
so
yeah let's go for
the
front this here let me just go ahead and
yeah let's do this
oh that's some rust in there oh we're
gonna need to take our time with this
oh that is some built up rust i could
use a metal cleaner but you know i got
to save my money
who knows when the developers are going
to put an even better washer in here
i'm really hoping that what it is is
like they'll have washers that are
specialized for uh certain types of
grime and stuff i know it says in the
description that it kinda is that way
right now but even though there's only
three washers one is clearly way better
than the others so you know this one is
the most powerful and it's just a
situation where you're like
yeah i guess i'll use that one you know
and by the way i do know about tab but
it's cheating much like many things of
this game like so
it's cheating
[Music]
[Music]
our driving miss pebbles live stream
flopped the fans just want esther so we
sold the car for a lot i mean a lot i
mean yes we do want to supersize
lot
all right then sorry about your live
stream but i guess you still made out
like a bandit but good this thing isn't
quite getting it i'll just go manual
this rust is baked into here i don't
think i've ever encountered rust quite
like this
huh i guess they wanted the last one to
be a thorough clean look at that go
that is stubborn
that is stubborn as hell
stubborn as a mule
stubborn is something that is incredibly
stubborn and no one ever better say me
how's this not me
not what i'm talking about god
damn
the rust
was with me was with me i did i i do
realize the absolute nonsense of my love
for this game like i get it i get it but
all memes aside
i'm gonna be very unapologetic
with my love for this game as i've been
in every episode there is no denying
the unbelievable satisfaction that comes
out of this game
and also just kind of like the pride you
can take
the job well done like bam look at that
all done now
[Music]
[Music]
come on you're clean
you're clean come on
you're clean come on
there you go good good good very good
very proud of you
[Music]
with enough time even the yellow can
take away uh rust i didn't know that
huh it's not perfect and you gotta go
real slow but maybe the coverage
actually is a little bit better
very nice
[Music]
i see you under there almost lost you
underneath the dirt
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just you know
just having a good time
also the filming for the sequel though
heist with markiplier is going very well
and uh i can't wait to show you guys
some of the stuff we have in store it's
going to be a bit you know we got a lot
more left to film but
man i've been having a good time out
here in austin filming just something
that i've been planning for so long
finally coming in to realities it's just
very very nice
i do like it
it is nice
not everyone gets to do that
i know that
and i cherish that
um
[Music]
[Music]
that's all the details on that side oh
now we get to do the dumb back all right
well i guess i'm excited about this
i know there's gonna be so much rust on
this bumper but i'm just clearing off
the the dust so i can
i can see what i'm working with i'm
probably just gonna clear up the whole
back side just because there is a lot of
rust here so let me just see how this is
going oh look there's logos under here
we raided the attic for all of esther's
old stuff and put it all on the vlog
it's gone bananas
i thought you said the live stream
flopped where are all these people
coming from do you know how vlogs work
and what's fascinated me the most is the
telemetry
the telema the telemetry the telemet the
telemetry look i don't really look at
analytics but i'm pretty sure that
telemetry isn't exactly a category there
[Music]
[Music]
oh the underbody i didn't even see the
undercarriage there okay
all right then
not a problem
[Music]
the underside that's literally the name
of this section the underside oh yes
thank you
i will definitely clear out
the underside god do you remember how
naive i was when i first played this
with that space rover i really thought
it was gonna be like a one video game i
was like ah okay this is gonna be pretty
cool didn't even know what the grime was
the difference between the different
dirts was didn't know anything i was so
young oh just fresh faced with nothing
but optimism and nothing no no idea of
the realities of life and cleanliness
just with dirt on my nose and rust on my
loins
i was nobody that was nothing then then
i became the premier youtube
whatever the power washing simulator
challenge channel that i am
i've come a long way
and i couldn't have done it without you
thank you for letting me be me
and being here to see me be me
and not getting in the way of me
being me i'm gonna have trouble with
this ladder i can tell
[Music]
[Music]
okay uh that's probably all that i can
do from this angle i think i actually do
have to get
up before i'm able to get anything else
you know
i almost feel like the white nozzle is a
little useless
because there are very few occasions
when i would consider it a good idea to
use the white nozzle unless it's just
like the most basic dirt but at that
point you get an upgrade and
i don't know you you get harder levels
so unless you're backtracking i guess
green's good he's not bad
i don't mind the green
jenny's changed too traded in
cryptozoology for cryptocurrency itty
bitty coin looks like the next big thing
if you need yeah okay thanks that's
exactly what i wanted in my fire washing
simulator experience get the world of
crypto and air thank you thank you for
that
i know i'm not getting it uh everything
perfect
um but i'm getting the majority of it
because biakuaz
i'm going to use soap for its intended
purpose which is to put a finishing
touch on everything and polish this bad
boy to a mirror finish because it's
mostly metal right if i was to really
role play my my my power washing
simulator here which i am and which i'm
doing i'm going to assume that the soap
is
really mainly there for uh
that sparkle that clean that fresh scent
at the end of the job so that you can
turn it back to the customer and they
can know that you really did your job
well
they can smell the clean that's really
what i want that's what i want for these
lovely people and that's what they're
gonna get let's get up here
while i'm up here i'm gonna spot the
goddamn rust that's still in this bumper
where are you where are you i wish i had
like a power washing grenade you know
what i mean
just something to really hone in on the
stupid pieces of junk that are trying to
hold out on me
get clean well this bumper is going to
be about a hunch
that's okay though
more challenge for me
oh there's all the grime on you okay
there we go
there we go
[Music]
the upshot of all this we want you to
have
oh
oh
for me
oh
what will you oh you oh you're so sweet
i was going to do this
this job so good for you you didn't tell
me it was for me i never would have
tried as hard
oh
maybe you could take your job to other
counties maybe you know someone on the
lookout for one oh
no it's you give it to me i'm not gonna
re-gift it oh that's too nice oh my gosh
i'm actually my heart is actually warm
from that
that's so nice
[Music]
[Music]
bam okay so that is all what meant to
stay up there hang on dramatic finish
no that's rust okay so that is all of
the grime i think all that's left now is
regular old rust so as i said i'm gonna
use this for its intended purpose which
is as a polisher
at the end of a job well done
really spit shine it up
really get this thing all nice
there we go
there it is
there it is
there it is
[Music]
that's what it's for because then you
get the nice like
feeling of clean
you know what i mean you get that
sensation that like oh yeah
oh that's a oh that's a
minty fresh clean there and if i could
just get the rest of this bumper all
cleaned up let me get the undercarriage
though
and that exhaust
definitely has some spots oh that
exhaust where's the where would that be
i don't see anything
oh there we go i see you gotcha
okay and then bumper
bumper thought i saw something there
ah there we go that's nice this is
practically done on this side
well let's give her all the old spit
shine
um
she's a beaut
she's a beard i i'm i need to be allowed
to tie more
[Music]
metal clean oh out of stock
really out of stock
what do you mean you're out of stock
do they get out of stock
is that a thing that happens why is my
no what that's time yeah i got
multi-purpose cleaner i'll be fine
ah
a thing of beauty
the multi-purpose cleaner has that minty
fresh that's what i'm really looking for
that's the only reason i'm really doing
this
just for that minty finish
almost done
[Music]
well this one definitely doesn't do
metal as well but i only got the tiniest
bit of metal left but let's let's put it
up there
as i'll run it out
there it goes let's get those last
things by hand
see some there let's get the turbo
yeah these guys at the top are still a
little bit of a bother
[Music]
oh there's still some dirt on the side
here
i know there's dirt all over this but i
didn't think man that multi-purpose
cleaner does not do as well as i thought
it would
[Music]
i saw a rust somewhere here
definitely said rust
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay brake lights i know it's these back
ones up here
[Music]
break lines all this bumper still
oh this bumper no way no is it the front
bumper
oh i thought i did this i thought i
heard it go ding i could have sworn i
heard it go ding okay whatever
indicators oh definitely these up tippy
top
[Applause]
hey
fa get yourself over here as quick as
you can we get wait what
what
that's a beautiful job
that's a beauty of a job
that's beautiful
now it's beautiful
oh it's a thing of beauty
that's a thing of beauty
but what did you say is it
i thought that was the last one
well
if that's the case
well i'm all out of time for this one
but
that's interesting to know
thank you for that pleasant surprise
thank you everybody so much for watching
i'll wait until there's another like
substantial update um before i do that
one because then i'll i'll maybe i'll
get something else or maybe i'll just do
that one on my own but thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for watching this series with me and
thank you for enjoying the luxury of
power washing and the
satisfaction of a job well done and a
job well clean so thank you and as
always i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you